y 150 000 viajes diarios en Los Ángeles.
Para darles un poco de perspectiva,
Uber en Los Ángeles
está haciendo 157 000 viajes diarios, hoy...
100 años más tarde.
Estos son los chicos de los troles,
el monopolio de transporte existente en ese momento.
Claramente no estaban contentos con el monstruo colectivo.
Por lo que se pusieron a trabajar
y fueron a las ciudades de todo el país
y consiguieron regulaciones para frenar el crecimiento del colectivo.
Había todo tipo de regulaciones.
Había licencias, a menudo caras.
En algunas ciudades,
si uno era conductor de colectivo,
tenía la obligación de estar en el colectivo durante 16 horas diarias.
En otras ciudades,
se requieren dos conductores por un colectivo.
Pero había una regulación muy interesante
que era que tenían que poner una luz en el asiento trasero
--instalarla en todos los jitney--
para detener una nueva innovación perniciosa que llamaron cucharita.
(Risas)
Bien. Entonces, ¿qué pasó?
Bueno, en un año esto se había acabado.
Pero el jitney, en 1919, fue regulado por completo fuera de existencia.
Eso es lamentable...
porque, cuando no se puede compartir el coche, entonces se tiene que tener uno.
Y la propiedad de coches se disparó
y no es de extrañar que para el 2007,
había un coche para cada hombre, mujer y niño en los EE. UU.
Y ese fenómeno se hizo global.
En China en 2011,
hubo más ventas de coches en China que en EE. UU.
Ahora, toda esta propiedad privada, por supuesto, tuvo un costo público.
En los EE. UU., pasamos 7 mil millones de horas al año,
desperdiciadas, sentados en el tráfico.
160 mil millones de dólares en pérdidas de productividad,
claro, también sentados en el tráfico,
y una quinta parte de todas las emisiones de carbono
son echadas al aire por esos coches en lo que estamos sentados.
Sin embargo, ahora eso es solo un 4 % de nuestros problemas.
Porque si tienen que poseer un coche
entonces eso significa que el 96 % de las veces su coche está inactivo.
Y así, hasta un 30 % de nuestra suelo y nuestro espacio
se utiliza para el almacenamiento de estos trozos de acero.
Incluso tenemos rascacielos construidos para los coches.
Ese es el mundo en que vivimos hoy.
Las ciudades se han ocupado de este problema desde hace décadas.
Se llama el transporte masivo.
E incluso en una ciudad como Nueva York,
una de las más densamente pobladas del mundo
y uno de los sistemas de transporte masivo más sofisticados del mundo,
todavía hay 2,5 millones de coches que pasan esos puentes todos los días.
¿Por qué es eso?
Bueno, es porque el transporte público aún no sabe
cómo llegar a las puertas de todo el mundo.
Y de vuelta en San Francisco, donde vivo,
la situación es mucho peor,
de hecho, mucho peor en todo el mundo.
Y así el inicio de Uber en 2010 fue...
bueno, solo queríamos apretar un botón y tener transporte.
No teníamos ninguna gran ambición.
Sin embargo, resultó
que mucha gente quería apretar un botón y tener transporte.
y en última instancia lo que empezamos a ver fue un montón de paseos duplicados.
Vimos a mucha gente
presionando el mismo botón al mismo tiempo
yendo esencialmente al mismo lugar.
Así que empezamos a pensar,
¿cómo podemos hacer que estos dos viajes y se conviertan en uno.
Porque si lo hacíamos, ese viaje sería mucho más barato
--hasta un 50 % más barato--
y claro para la ciudad
tendríamos mucha más gente y muchos menos coches.
Y así, la gran pregunta para nosotros fue:
¿funcionaría?
¿Se podría tener un viaje más barato,
tan barato que la gente estuviera dispuesta a compartirlo?
Y la respuesta, afortunadamente, es un sí rotundo.
En San Francisco,
antes de uberPOOL, tuvimos...
bueno, todo el mundo tendría su coche donde diablos quisiera.
Los colores brillantes es donde tenemos más coches.
Una vez que introducimos uberPOOL,
se ve que no hay tantos colores brillantes.
Más gente moviéndose por la ciudad en menos coches,
sacando coches de las calles.
Parece que uberPOOL está trabajando.
Y así lo pusimos en marcha en Los Ángeles
hace ocho meses.
Y desde entonces, hemos tomado 12,7 millones de km de las calles
y 1,4 miles de toneladas métricas de CO2 del aire.
Pero la parte de la que estoy realmente...
(Aplausos)
Pero mi estadística favorita...
recuerden soy de Los Ángeles,
pasé años de mi vida
sentado al volante pensando, "¿Cómo podemos solucionar esto?",
mi parte favorita es que 8 meses después,
añadimos 100 000 nuevas personas al uso del coche compartido todas las semanas.
Ahora, en China todo es tamaño súper,
y por lo que estamos haciendo 15 millones de viajes uberPOOL al mes,
eso es de 500 000 por día.
Claro que estamos viendo que se da un crecimiento exponencial.
De hecho, lo vemos en Los Ángeles, también.
Cuando hablo con mi equipo, no hablamos de,
"Bueno, 100 000 personas comparten el coche todas las semanas y listo".
¿Cómo podemos llegar al millón?
Y en China, que podría ser de varios millones.
Y así uberPOOL es una gran solución para compartir el coche urbano.
Pero ¿qué pasa con los suburbios?
Esta es la calle donde crecí en Los Ángeles,
es un suburbio llamado Northridge, California,
y bueno...
miren, esos buzones, del tipo de que están para siempre.
Y todas las mañanas más o menos al mismo tiempo,
coches salen de las casas,
la mayoría de ellos, una persona en el coche,
y van a trabajar, van a su lugar de trabajo.
Nuestra pregunta es:
bien, ¿cómo convertirmos
a todos estos coches de los suburbios
--y literalmente hay decenas de millones de ellos--
¿cómo los convertimos a todos en coches compartidos?
Tenemos algo para esto lanzado recientemente llamado uberCOMMUTE.
Se levantan en la mañana, se preparan para el trabajo, su café,
van a su coche,
encienden la aplicación de Uber,
y, de repente,
se convierten en un conductor de Uber.
Y van a coincidir con uno de sus vecinos
en su camino al trabajo
y es una cosa realmente grande.
Solo hay un obstáculo...
se llama regulación.
Así que 54 centavos por milla, ¿qué es eso?
Bueno, eso es lo que el gobierno de EE. UU.
ha determinado que es el costo de poseer un coche por milla.
Puedes recoger a quien sea en EE. UU.
y llevarlo a donde quiera ir en cualquier momento,
por 54 centavos por milla o menos.
Pero si cobras 60 centavos por milla, eres un criminal.
Pero ¿qué tal si por 60 centavos por milla
pudiéramos conseguir medio millón más de personas en coche compartido en L.A.?
¿Y si con 60 centavos por milla
pudiéramos obtener que 50 millones de personas compartieran el coche en EE. UU.?
Si pudiéramos,
obviamente es algo que debemos hacer.
Y así volvamos a la lección del jitney.
Si en el año 1915 esta cosa hubiera despegado,
imaginen sin las regulaciones que se dieron,
si solo hubiera podido seguir.
¿Cómo serían nuestras ciudades de diferentes hoy?
¿Tendríamos parques en lugar de estacionamiento?
Pues bien, perdimos esa oportunidad.
Pero la tecnología nos ha dado otra oportunidad.
Estoy tan emocionado como cualquiera sobre los coches auto-conducidos,
pero ¿tenemos que esperar realmente 5, 10 o incluso 20 años
para que nuestras nuevas ciudades sean una realidad?
Con la tecnología de hoy en nuestros bolsillos,
y un poco de regulación inteligente,
podemos convertir cada coche en un coche compartido,
y podemos recuperar nuestras ciudades a partir de hoy.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
Chris Anderson: Travis, gracias.
Travis Kalanick: Gracias.
CA: Quiero decir... la empresa que crearon es absolutamente sorprendente.
Solo hablaste de una pequeña parte de ella aquí
--una parte poderosa--
la idea de convertir los coches en transporte público así,
es genial.
Pero tengo un par de otras preguntas
porque sé que están en la mente de las personas.
En primer lugar, la semana pasada, creo que fue,
encendí mi teléfono y traté de reservar un Uber
y no pude encontrar la aplicación.
Sacaron este nuevo diseño muy audaz valiente muy radical.
TK: Seguro.
CA: ¿Cómo te fue?
¿Vieron que otros no encontrar la aplicación ese día?
¿Van a ganar gente por este nuevo diseño?
TK: Primero debo probablemente solo decir,
lo que estábamos tratando de lograr.
Creo que si sabes un poco de nuestra historia,
tiene mucho más sentido.
Es que, cuando arrancamos al inicio,
era solo coches negros.
Literalmente era presionar un botón y tener un S-Class.
Y así lo hicimos
Era lo que yo llamaría una versión inmadura de una marca de lujo
que parecía la tarjeta de identificación de un coche de lujo.
Y a medida que vamos a todo el mundo
y pasamos de S-Clases a mototaxis en la India,
se convirtió en algo importante para nosotros
ser más accesibles,
ser más "hiperlocales",
serlo en las ciudades en que estábamos
y eso es lo que se ve con los patrones y colores.
Y para ser más icónicos,
porque una U no quiere decir nada en sánscrito,
y una U no significa nada en mandarín.
Y así que fue un poco de lo qué se trataba.
Ahora, la primera vez que despliegas algo por el estilo,
es decir, tus manos están sudando,
tienes...
sabes, estás un poco preocupado.
Lo que vimos es que mucha gente
en realidad, al principio, vimos mucha más gente abriendo la aplicación
porque curiosidad de lo que encontrarían cuando la abrieran.
Y nuestros números fueron ligeramente arriba de lo que esperábamos.
CA: Bien, genial.
Ahora, tú, tú mismo, eres una especie de enigma, diría.
Tus inversores y seguidores que han estado contigo todo este tiempo
creen que la única oportunidad
del tipo de enfrentarse a los poderosos intereses arraigados,
de industria del taxi y así sucesivamente,
es tener a alguien que es un competidor feroz, implacable,
como sin duda has demostrado ser.
Algunos sienten que han llevado esta cultura demasiado lejos,
y sabes... al igual que hace un año o dos
hubo una gran controversia en la que muchas mujeres fueron molestadas.
¿Cómo se sintieron al interior de la empresa durante ese período?
¿Se dieron cuenta de una pérdida de negocio?
¿Aprendiste algo de eso?
TK: Bueno, mira, creo...
He sido empresario desde la escuela secundaria
y tienes...
de varias formas diferentes un empresario verá tiempos difíciles
y para nosotros,
fue hace un año y medio,
y para nosotros fueron tiempos difíciles también.
Ahora, en el interior, nos sentimos como...
creo que al final del día sentimos
que éramos buenas personas que hacen un buen trabajo,
pero en el exterior eso no era evidente.
Y así que había muchas cosas que teníamos que hacer
una especie de...
pasamos de una empresa muy pequeña...
me refiero si vas, literalmente, dos y medio años atrás,
nuestra empresa era de 400 personas,
y en la actualidad es de 6500.
Y así, cuando tienes ese crecimiento,
tienes como que cimentar tus valores culturales
y hablar de ellos todo el tiempo.
Y asegurarte de que la gente constantemente se pregunte,
"¿Somos buenas personas que hacen un buen trabajo?".
Y si compruebas bien eso,
la siguiente parte es asegurarte de que están contando tu historia.
Creo que aprendimos mucho de la experiencia
pero creo que al final salimos más fuertes.
Pero sin duda fue un período difícil.
CA: Me parece, a donde vas,
estás frente a personas que de vez en cuando te dan un mal rato.
Algunos conductores Uber en Nueva York y en otros lugares
están furiosos porque has cambiado las cuotas
y apenas pueden --afirman-- permitirse repartir más.
Cómo...
has dicho que Uds. han iniciado esto originalmente...
solo por la maravilla de presionar un botón y tener transporte.
Esto ha tenido éxito,
afectas toda la economía mundial, básicamente, en este punto.
Estás siendo forzado a ser, quiéraslo o no,
una especie de visionario mundial que está cambiando el mundo.
Quiero decir... ¿quién eres?
¿Quieres eso?
¿Estás listo para esto y ser lo que se necesita?
TK: Bueno, hay varias cosas juntas en esa pregunta, así que...
(Risas)
En primer lugar está lo de fijación de precios...
Es decir, recordermos, ¿no?
UberX, cuando empezamos,
era, literalmente, 10 o 15 % más barato que nuestro producto coche negro.
Ahora,
en muchas ciudades, es la mitad del precio de un taxi.
Y tenemos todos los datos que muestran
que los conductores están haciendo más por hora que lo que harían como taxistas.
Lo que pasa es que cuando el precio baja,
las personas son más propensas a tomar Uber
en diferentes momentos del día que de otra manera harían,
y en sitios que los que no lo hubiera hecho antes.
Es decir, para un conductor, donde sea que deje a alguien
tendrá más posiblidad de recoger a alguien y seguir andando.
Y eso significa más viajes por hora,
más minutos de la hora que son productivos
y, de hecho, las ganancias suben.
Tenemos ciudades en las que hemos hecho, literalmente, 5 o 6 recortes de precios
y hemos visto que los recortes aumentan con el tiempo.
Así que incluso en Nueva York,
tenemos una entrada en el blog que llamamos "4 septiembres",
que compara los resultados
septiembre tras septiembre tras septiembre.
Mismo mes cada año.
Y vemos las ganancias subiendo con el tiempo
conforme baja el precio.
Hay un punto de precio perfecto, no se puede bajar para siempre.
Y en aquellos lugares en los que bajas el precio
pero no vemos que los resultados suban,
subimos los precios.
Esto para la primera parte.
Y ahora el enigma y todo esto...
Es decir, el tipo de empresario que soy
es uno que se pone muy entusiasmo en la solución de problemas difíciles.
Me gusta de describirlo como algo así como un profesor de matemáticas.
¿Sabes? Si un profesor de matemáticas no tiene problemas difíciles de resolver,
ese es un profesor de matemáticas muy triste.
Así en Uber nos gustan los problemas difíciles
y nos gusta estar entusiasmados en ellos y resolverlos.
Pero no cualquier problema de matemáticas,
sino los más difíciles que podamos encontrar,
y queremos que si lo resuelves,
hay un poco de un factor sorpresa.
CA: En un par de años,
digamos 5 años, no sé cuando,
sacarán los increíbles coches auto-conducidos,
probablemente a un menor costo al que se paga hoy por un viaje de Uber.
¿Qué le dices a tu ejército de más de un millón de conductores en ese momento?
TK: Otra vez, ¿en qué momento?
CA: Cuando salgan los coches auto-conduccidos
TK: Claro, claro, claro. Lo siento, me perdí.
CA: ¿Qué le dices a un conductor?
TK: Bueno, mira, creo que la primera parte es que va a tomar...
que probablemente tome mucho más tiempo
de lo que creo que algunos medios de comunicación esperan.
Esa es la primera parte.
Lo segundo es que también va a tomar tiempo,
que va a ser una transición larga.
Estos coches funcionarán en ciertos lugares y en otros no.
Para nosotros es un reto interesante, ¿verdad?
Porque, bueno...
Google ha estado invirtiendo en eso desde el año 2007,
Tesla va a estar haciéndolo, Apple va a estar haciéndolo,
los fabricantes van a hacerlo.
Ese es un mundo que va a existir y por buenas razones.
Un millón de personas mueren al año en los coches.
Ya recuperamos miles de millones, incluso billones de horas en todo el mundo
que la gente gasta sentada en ellos, conduciendo frustrada, ansiosa.
Y pensar en la calidad de vida que mejora
cuando le devuelves tiempo a la gente
y les quitas ansiedad.
Así que creo que hay mucho bien.
Y así, la manera en que pensamos sobre esto es que es un reto,
pero uno para el liderazgo optimista,
Donde en vez de resistirse,
resistirse a la tecnología,
tal vez como la industria del taxi, o en la industria del trole,
tenemos que aceptarla o ser parte del futuro.
Pero ¿cómo liderar con optimismo a través de él?
¿Hay forma de asociarse con las ciudades?
¿Hay formas de tener los sistemas de educación, formación profesional, etc.,
para ese período de transición?
Llevará más tiempo de lo que creo que todos esperamos,
sobre todo ese período de transición.
Pero es un mundo que va a existir
y que va a ser un mundo mejor.
CA: Travis, lo que construyes es absolutamente increíble
y estoy muy agradecido de que hayas venido a TED de manera tan abierta.
Muchas gracias. TK: Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)